okay thank you good evening and welcome
to this strategy and resources committee
uh meeting on the 20th of July
my name is councilor Mark Durham and I'm
the chairperson of this committee
members we are streaming the meeting
live as well as recording by being
present in the meeting you're giving
your consent to be recorded during each
item please put your hand up to indicate
if you wish to speak I'll then invite
you at the appropriate time and could
ask members to avoid approaching the top
table as this could create interference
with the camera's live stream please
note that the YouTube live stream sound
recording is dependent on the correct
use of your microphones
therefore can I ask when invited to
speak you remember turn your microphone
on and turn it off when finished please
reference a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers and
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible and I will add the
bit and please avoid repeating comments
that have been previously made item two
apologies for absence Tara
Catherine Neal is attending as a
substitute for cancer stamp and cancer
species attending as a substitute for
cancer Journey
okay
thank you item three minutes it's
recommended that the meetings the
minutes of the meeting held on the 22nd
of June 2023 to be found on pages 5 to
76 are approved as a true and accurate
record I say move do I have a second
before that please thank you councilor
fluka
members any items of accuracy from those
minutes
okay can we agree that by a cent thank
you very much indeed item four
Declarations of interest interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests are
there registerable interests or
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members members
you're also reminded that you are
required to disclose such an interest as
soon as they become aware should the
nasal ride need arise through the
meeting members any Declarations of
Interest I declare myself
um as uh
I have been involved in discussions at
Essex County Council about the waste
strategy although I'm not the decision
maker on that item
and that would be for Mr quelch uh and
other registerable interest
okay item six on the agenda
uh North Essex economic board refresh
strategy and delivery plan and you'll
find that members on pages 77 to 154 and
who is presenting this
we I'm not I know you want to get away
counselor but we're not going to stifle
debate
in respect to my 105 which is
oh okay okay sorry our missed item five
public participation that we have none
so we've now moved back on to item six
and um
and it's cable thank you
thank you chairman and good evening
members the purposes of this report is
to provide an update on the continued
positive benefits of the North Essex
economic board partnership and to seek
approval of the refresh strategy and
delivery plan for the benefit of new
members I will give some background
information on the North Essex economic
board
in 2019 tendering Colchester Braintree
Oxford and Essex councils agreed to
develop an economic strategy that would
articulate the strengths weaknesses and
opportunities of the North Essex
economic Corridor initially inspired by
the ninja articulate a vision associated
with but independent from the North
Essex Garden communities
the North Essex economic board known as
neeb was formed to oversee the
development of the strategy the informal
board consists of leader and Cabinet
member representatives from each local
Authority and a complimentary officer
Steering group was formed to deliver the
work
Chelmsford and Malden councils joined
neeb in May 2020 and the need now covers
half of the second tier authorities in
Essex
towards the end of 2020 need Partners
agreed to allocate 10 of their
additional restrictions grant funding to
support a coordinated program of
business skills and support
this contribute collaboration yielded
1.6 million in jointly commission
projects plus an additional Financial
commitment from Essex County Council
the business support and skills program
produced the benefits that are listed on
page 78 of your report pack
the UK share Prosperity fund or UK SPF
as it's known has provided a new
opportunity for collaboration
each local Authority has agreed to
commit up to 10 percent of its
authorities Revenue allocation for years
two and three of the UK SPF to develop
collaborative initiatives with neeb
need Partners continue to work together
and have commissioned an updated North
Essex economic strategy this update
reflects Malden and Chelmsford councils
joining the post-covered landscape and
the current economic shocks the UK is
experiencing
henham strategy limited were appointed
via robust and thorough procurement
process to deliver the refresh strategy
and delivery plan extensive evidence
Gathering consisting of strategic
analysis data scrutiny and stakeholder
workshops facilitated the development of
the refresh strategy and plan officers
from the partner authorities have also
been involved at every stage of this
work to ensure parity and representation
of need and opportunity
the refreshed strategy and delivery plan
which is appendix one of this report
sets out the North Essex Vision the
economic context the North Essex
strategic priorities North Essex essex's
opportunities the two-year delivery plan
and the Ambitions of North Essex
a series of Officer workshops are
planned during 2023 to develop specific
actions to support the two-year delivery
plan and ensuring success
and in conclusion the new partnership
provides a cohesive strategic oversight
of North Essex diverse inclusive and
productive economic priorities ensuring
tangible actions are delivered to
support residents and businesses goals
and aspirations promoting the Region's
potential the knee presents the strong
strategic rationale for further central
government and private sector investment
needed to deliver North essex's
long-term Ambitions thank you and I have
to take any questions
um thank you very much I'm just going to
ask one question and myself before I
open to members in that you're opening
Gambit you said that the leader and
Cabinet member I know we haven't got a
cabinet but I understand it's just the
leader sits on this from Malden is that
correct
that's correct sorry if I I misspoke I
meant leader or Cabinet member Authority
um members
uh uh Council of siddles indicated first
of all that councilor flicker was going
for his trigger
councilor siddle thank you chair I'd
just like to you know say how important
this initiative and strategy is for the
modern District uh
it's yeah it's good that we signed up to
it it's pity that we weren't there
weren't there at the start uh to exploit
the opportunities that are available
through this partnership and yeah having
been involved in some of the workshops
around along with councilor white uh
when him were doing their investigation
they were extremely beneficial and yeah
the report that Herman had produced
gives a fantastic Direction and strategy
for the North Essex economic board to
move forward and all the councils that
are involved in that
can't disagree any other members
councilor white uh thank you Shannon um
yeah now I'd just like to thank Lena for
her hard work on doing it and obviously
we need all the funding we can get the
only thing I find is a bit disappointing
is I've read through the entire report
and Malden isn't mentioned the only
thing that is mentioned on page 99 is
the one Malden District
um so that was a bit disappointing so
um do we have any new projects coming up
and are they you know because they talk
about when they did their studies the uh
prospective jobs
um but when they did this for the other
regions they were saying well we're
developing this this and this um and I
wondered if there was any update on what
Malden were doing because I get the
outcomes I get the what we want to
achieve but it's just a bit
disappointing that it's not really
modern's not really being mentioned
thank you
thank you councilor white and there is
reference on page
92 which is of the yeah Beijing survey
gender pack about Morgan actually
Leading The Way of onshore wind and in
fact we create the most onshore wind
power throughout the North Essex area
uh
so would you like to come back before I
continue I won't come back just
um that was uh in place a long time
before we joined this this is ongoing
and uh not all the members are too
impressed and um also it it's not that
uh terribly successful but um but I'd
like to see projects moving forward not
things that we did 10 15 years ago or
how long ago it was we did the wind
farms I can't remember I don't really
see how that's relevant because
obviously that was agreed
when I first got elected I think
um and what I'd like to see is where
we're going to you know not not where we
are and what we've done historically I
want to see what we're aiming to provide
the jobs where we're going with them I
just want to see more of the future of
what we're trying to achieve you know I
want to see a vision of what we want to
get and I said I know you're really good
at getting funding but I want to see
where we're going what we're aiming for
and how we're going to achieve it you
know how we're going to provide these
jobs are we going to have hubs are we
you know I want to see what what are we
doing to to get the the bang for our
buck thank you
it's only days yet but cable have you
got an answer apologies councilor I
misinterpreted your question which I
thought was specific about the reference
to Malden within this document so the
workshops that are in fact I attended
the first workshop on Monday with only
Partners to begin building that action
plan which very much will start to
deliver this strategy so we're talking
about what particular areas do we want
to focus on how we're going to do it and
how we can collaborate together to get
best value for money to achieve those
tangible outcomes you mentioned that
support the strategy right councilor
fluke thank you yeah thanks chairman I
mean the irony of the wind farms isn't
lost on me because it was actually the
Secretary of State who Eric pickles who
believed it he's a law now Lord pickles
um he ran rough shot over this Council
and approved them against massive uh you
know pushback from local residents but
that's how we got those and and what's
their contribution well I know one of
the companies that's involved in
maintenance they reckon that on average
one or two employees on general
maintenance so what whilst it might be a
huge contribution to uh Rew the people
that own them I'm not sure what comes
back to us uh although obviously we get
the ndr but I mean this is you know this
is
um you know pretty run-of-the-mill
report I'm never comfortable chairman
when I read things in pet like in
paragraph six Roman four when it says
further Financial contributions may be
required well we don't really have an
awful lot of spare dollar uh in this
Corporation and I think we need to sort
of understand you know what our
liabilities could be
um if we're going to move forward with
these projects but rarely speaking
chairman there's there's really nothing
wrong with this and I propose that we
agree the recommendations thank you well
I'm I'm guessing councilor fluka that as
and when projects come along though the
need for the investment will be balanced
against the potential returns so we can
make that decision at that time members
we are being asked to continue the
support and approve the adoption of the
refresh North Essex economic board
strategy
members agreed thank you very much
indeed
um item
seven
interestingly looking for the agenda
again
item seven treasury management out turn
report
2223 and miss Lucas
sure
um so purpose of their report
um is to report on the council's
investment activity for the financial
year
22-23 and in accordance with sitva's
treasury management code and our own
treasury management policy and practices
um just to provide a little context to
the report the council's treasury
management strategy is approved each
year and it was presented to this
committee on the 3rd of February 2022
and then was subsequently approved by
Council on 24th of February
local authorities are required to report
on the performance of their treasury
management function at least twice a
year at the in the middle of the year
and at year end
and this report fulfills the year-end um
function for last year
um the council currently engages link
groups to provide treasury management
consultancy and advice services and
appendix one
um sets out some further information
provided by Link in terms of the
overview of the external economic
environment that the council and others
face
um so at paragraph 3.7 we just summarize
the investment activity for the last
Financial year
I just like to remind members that both
the Sip for code and government guidance
require the council to invest its funds
prudently and that we must have regard
to the security of our investments and
the liquidity before we seek the optimum
rate of return or yield
the council's objective when investing
money is to strike that appropriate
balance between risk and return and
minimize any risk of incurring losses
so June 22-23 the council had an average
of 32.3 million pounds invested
and that is broken down in more detail
at um the table at 3.73
just to move on to
paragraph 3.8 of the report where we set
out the performance in terms of what we
achieved
um from our investments so that sets out
the average investment rate return
achieved on each of the investment types
that the council holds
um members might already be aware that
we overachieved on our investment income
last year and that was partly due to the
increased interest rates
um driven Again by kind of high
inflation rates
um so paragraph 3.9 of the reports we
report our compliance with our
Prudential indicators and our own
strategy and I can confirm that all
Prudential indicators were complied with
during the year
um with the exception that on a few
occasions
um the council's bank balance
limits of three million pounds and went
slightly over due to cash flow
management but that's set out within the
report
and appendix to provide some further
detail on our compliance with those
potential indicators
um so in conclusion I'd just like to say
that the um yeah the requirements of the
Sip for code of practice
um have been met um over the last
Financial year
um and
as I've said previously a prudent
approach has been intaken in relation to
the investment activity with um priority
being given to the security and
liquidity of our investments over any
yield
um if members have got any questions I'm
happy to try and answer thank you thank
you so the recommendation members is
that you review the treasury out and
report from a compliance perspective any
questions for the officer councilor
siddle
thank you chair I just are the I chart
that's on 3.7.3 and our investment in
local authorities uh obviously uh after
thoracic last year are we ensuring that
we don't go down any of those routes or
where there might be risk to our
investments I know we I know we weren't
really at risk because it's all
guaranteed anyway but yeah are we are we
thinking about where that where we go to
with that money yeah and so through your
chair um
yeah so local authorities aren't credit
rated in the same way as other
Investments are but as you say aren't
the sort of underlying risk of local
Authority Investments generally is is
very low because they are essentially
backed by government and even in the
case of historic
um everyone had all of their Investments
fully repaid
um but we do obviously take our I do our
own internal monitoring of any
authorities that we feel are
particularly risky and we keep our own
lists of those that we are prepared to
invest in so yeah we are very cognizant
of that risk thank you
if there's any other questions yes
counselor driver first and councilor
fluke thank you chair
um given the recent uh rise in interest
rates well over the last year and they
have continued to rise though may have
flattened out now we'll see
does that have any implications for us
okay thank you and
so yeah they've sort of continued High
interest rates at the moment were
factored into the budget as far as we
could forecast so we take independent
advice from our treasury advisors in
terms of the future interest rate
forecasts and they they are sort of
built into our budgetary forecast for
this year obviously um no one's got a
crystal ball so they that is monitored
throughout the year and it's possible we
will still overachieve on that this year
obviously we have to take a long-term
View and um we would expect that
interest rates would start to fall
gradually over time so we do factor that
into our um medium-term financial
planning
cancer driver is you know obviously this
time last year we had no idea that
interest rates were so the bonus that we
had of 400 000 last year was completely
unexpected but of course now we've got
the benefit of being able to predict
using the bank of England's predictions
um as to what they are going to be
councilor Fluker you are next I'm glad
that you put your finger up in here and
alluded to Tracy on the mix but there we
go
um a couple of questions
um chairman through you
um on the 6th of February the government
issued uh an order to investigate
eastleigh by our council's finances
um and whilst I'd accept that all all
low needs to local authorities that
they're underwritten by the government
they all have to be treated the same but
if there's a six month default for one
local Authority then that's the same for
all local authorities and and that was a
piece of information that was passed to
me but um from the last 151 officer so I
think that's birth bearing in mind
particularly so there's an awful lot of
stuff out there about eastleigh Council
uh and whilst roundly speaking our money
is protected one wonders
um
what sort of a deal we've got with
easily what's the return bearing in mind
last week you know NatWest
um was offering their Premier Bank
account holders 6.2 fixed for 12 months
and so is Coots uh minimum investment of
100 Grand you know these are Big figures
I suspect they'll start to Tumble if
they haven't already done that but I was
just you know I just wanted to make sure
that we are watching the eastleigh
position carefully and whether or not
we'd be better off
um better off investing somewhere else
and
um I may have missed it but
um have we now appointed Link in place
of Arlington close that you used to do
our sort of used to provide that
Financial background investment
information and
is link investing on behalf of us or are
we investing
following their directions and and what
are we actually paying link for their
services
quite a few questions thank you thank
you chair and
yeah so um
councilor Lucas correct that and
obviously the report says that we had
some uh two million pounds invested in
eastleigh Council that investment was
made before there was some of this kind
of press activity and obviously we would
take that into account now going going
forward
um on the second Point
um yeah so the council reprocute its
treasury management advice Services
um and
um link was procured um over all in
closer there are new treasury advisors
going forward
um in terms of the amount that that
contracts crossed I'm not sure I've got
that on my fingertips
um I might have to provide an answer
outside of the meeting but
um yeah in essence we take Link's advice
and they provide a sort of framework for
investment
um within our risk appetite but they do
not invest on our behalf we we make
those investment decisions but in view
of their advice
okay happy with that yeah if there's any
consolation Council later if you haven't
done already I would read the BBI report
patharic if you want to
be completely
put it have your mind full at rest about
our situation councilor white thank you
chairman yeah just to say that I'm I'm
I'm sure that Mr Lucas is going to be
the same as Mr Leslie and we're in a
safe Pair of Hands
um and when you go on to appendix 2
um as as
um uh page 175 as
um the other members will know I was and
and the chairman himself indeed um I was
a very prudent uh chair and I'm sure
that we'll continue that because I was
always nervous about a lot of these
projects that were put forward and I
think and also the borrowing that was
recommended and I'm actually really
pleased we're in the position we were
and where is the bigger authorities used
to look down and laugh at mold and
suddenly you know what we're actually
doing quite well thank you very much I
mean obviously long term we've got um
concerns so just to say that I hope that
we continue on in the same vein of as
being prudent of protecting the
residents who need it but being really
careful where we spend and trying to cut
borrowing because obviously it's now now
that we're reaping the benefits so let's
look forward to the future thank you
members are you happy with this report
thank you very much indeed moving on
item eight is the uh fraud policies on
page 177 and that's Miss cardi I believe
good evening
uh I'd just like to introduce the
purpose of this recall is to seek
approval for the refreshed fraud
policies which require review every
three years
policies are attached at the appendices
and are the anti-fold and Corruption
mentee money laundering and the bribery
Act
it is obviously obviously imperative for
NDC to have all policies in place which
are shared with all the staff and
supported by robust processing and
guidance to protect NDC from Financial
abroad
I undertook the review of the policies
with the director of resources who is
also the section 1151 officer at the
time
um and the deputy section 151 officer
who's the lead to finance manager
it was also undertaking with advice from
our internal Auditors and in using best
practices from other local Authority
policies
our extended leadership team reviewed
the draft policies and feedback received
was incorporated into the recall
there were no material changes to the
existing provinces but changes were made
to align with other MDC policies that
have been updated and our current
structure as adult titles
um members are asked to review and
improve the policies for use in a
further review in three years time in
2025-26
if there's any questions I would be
happy to answer
members councilor white uh thank you Mr
chewing um mine's a general run really
um obviously we do work at work
um with the financial industry
um and well I haven't seen the report is
briefly mentioned or sort of alluded to
him once uh page 1199
um we are um banned by a duty that we
have to report anything self-report
anything that we think may be linked in
any way to AML or anything similar
um does the council have the same policy
that they will
um self-report if they think there's any
suspicions because uh I thought it was
an offense not to and I say my mistake
if I haven't seen it in here but I
didn't see it mentioned and it was just
something I want to double check because
we have to do that at work Miss cardi
[Music]
um
why only would you have anything from a
financial
protection 151 few of that
um
thank you yeah um I think as the
counselor says um it's sort of alluded
to in the report that you know if we had
any suspicion or you know um
knowledge of any kind of wrongdoing then
we would um you know self-report
ourselves on that probably immediately
yeah
it's generally a duty of the the
controller yeah I mean I'd have to check
in terms of the public sector
legislation specifically I think you're
right in terms of the private sector
that there is a clear directive on that
I'm not 100 sure as I say on the
legislation around that for local
authorities but we can certainly need to
check that and come back to you thank
you okay councilor spenceley thank you
chair um but it's an obvious group of uh
policies to go together and they will
look fine to me sometimes it's helpful
to see related policies listed perhaps
on the top sheet but just one I was
thinking of was the whistleblowing
policy how recently was that renewed
I'm not I'm not sure where that can is
figures with fraud but
I suppose it might yes Miss cardi
we'll have to check that but that's
certainly something that needs to be
reviewed that I can undertake that
yeah it was just considering it in terms
of culture and we certainly have a
whistleblown policy but um
yeah in respect of fraud I think we'll
have to get back to you on that
members uh we need to agree this report
that is the recommendation is that by
sent thank you very much indeed
uh item nine is the consultation into
Essex waste strategy and that's page
211 and I think that will be Miss love
I'm not much mistaken good evening Carol
good evening
hopefully you can hear me okay we can
play partnership
is of all two-tier Essex accounts with
member representative supported by of
the group
the purpose is to review and investigate
with management approaches at complex
explore opportunities for joint working
and make recommendations on the
Strategic approaches to the delivery of
Waste Services ethics
the ewp is attended by representatives
from lawn district council at officer
level myself and also at member level
the current weight strategies for Essex
which is adopted in 2007 needs to be
updated as the reset changes in
legislation and also the current
Ambitions of members of the Essex waste
partnership so over the last 18 months
there have been several workshops
attended by office and members from all
13 and six councils and they've been
actively engaged and
working on this strategy and developing
it going forward
District Council has provided data for
broadcast modeling and scenario planning
and has also contributed to Vision
setting and identity identified
strategic priorities
Essex County Council is requesting that
the consultation public consultation
goes out to stakeholders and the public
and of course ourselves on behalf of the
partnership rather than themselves
however they will manage the
consultation on behalf of the
partnership
this strategy will provide a framework
for the next 30 year whereby Essex
authorities can work together to reduce
waste to protect the environment and
conserve resources
I was at the council NPC will still have
control over how it collects wastelands
oh how it does its way Services going
forward but of course we'll have to
follow that little legislation and the
strategy may have to change the time
depending upon government Direction
because there's a there's still a piece
of consultation that we don't know the
results of
I'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much about councilor
fluke has first yeah thanks Jim I mean
this is you know
reviewing the way that waste is
collected throughout the counties you
know
um you know I think it's probably it's
been going forever you know to me it's
you know every every local Authority
seems to almost be doing it a different
way so I think it's important to have
this
um
I think you know from my perspective and
I do communicate with with Miss love
quite a lot as she knows although not
much lately but yeah I think we should
all pay tribute to the to uh the service
that the waste provider you know I mean
you know it's a long time since we've
said this but you know particularly
during covert they never let us down and
I think they're doing a really good job
out there at the moment certainly in my
world which we've had enormous problems
with in the past
um you know I I might have misheard it
but I think that this you know if we're
going to run a public consultation I
would have thought there'd be some kind
of a cost there unless Essex are going
to pick up the bill
um but I just wondered if perhaps
through you chairman the 151 officer or
somebody could confirm that there are no
costs because that's what it says in
implications which surprises me because
it always is a cost I'm pretty sure uh
having been at the most recent meeting
and having been involved in this that
the cost is being born by Essex County
Council
yes you're quite right I think this is
in relation to the the old strategy
becoming out of date
due to legislation legislation for
example that is going to prevent
um landfill in the next couple of years
so clearly
um that is going to
you know if you can't bury it what do
you do with it there's only one other
solution unfortunately
um so yeah I think that the the
environment has
changed in terms of uh waste disposal
and I think you know I think it's
important members understand that
the the districts and City councils
are responsible for the collection and
the County Council is responsible for
the disposal
and out of 14 districts are actually 12
different methods of collection which
does pose it's its own its own problems
but um the the districts have no right
of dictating how it's disposed of and
the county has no right telling
districts how to collect it but it would
seem that
pragmatic discussion
will be ongoing so
um yes councilor White
thank you instrument
um I'd just like to thank Mr love
because it was really quite amusing we
went to a meeting about the waste
Collections and Essex were promoting
what everybody else should be doing and
we were already doing all of them so we
were head over the curve on that one
thanks to all the work and then I wanted
to raise is um although I don't have a
problem with the online booking I read
somewhere
um that some authorities had reverted
back and away from the online booking
and I wondered how it was going
um as a district no6 wide because I
can't it's annoying me now I can't
remember who it was who'd reverted back
to the original system and and how it
was working thank you
well uh yeah I think you're talking
about the recycling centers in that case
the booking system and as I as I'm I'm
unaware that anybody has reverted
because it's a County Council
responsibility the way recycling centers
are County Council and the trial is
still ongoing
I might come back this might have been
another area I can't remember now and I
I didn't think to make a note of it
before I came I just wondered if anybody
heard anything about council's reverting
I don't think it will be in Essex
um but as I said the trial is still on
ongoing
um but on the whole like it has actually
been quite successful the current Mrs
Durham is extremely happy with it
because she went today
um councilor driver just in response to
that uh since I used the Malden
recycling center quite a bit
um there's nobody there I mean I used to
queue uh not long queues but I used to
queue for five minutes I never queue now
not because actually it's very busy and
it's very efficient in terms of turn
around it's because people aren't using
it
uh and the staff they recognize that
so I I use the booking system my book I
go immediately I booked and just turn up
uh so I
I'm not quite sure where the waste is
now going if it's not going to the
recycling center because clearly there's
a lot of people now not using it thank
you well I know there was an initial
concern that it would increase fly
tipping but that unfortunately doesn't
seem to be the case but these things are
going to be evaluated at the end of the
trial so members we are being asked in
the recommendations to agree to
participate in the strategy and when the
strategy is published and we have our
results that our views are sought as a
committee
thank you very much indeed
okay well done members so that concludes
the main part of the meeting and we now
have to move into exclusion of the press
and public
so I result that under section 100 a
part four of the Local Government Act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business on the ground that they involve
the likely disclosure of
exempt information as defined in
paragraph
three of part one is scheduled 12a to
the ACT and this satisfies the public
interest test do I have a seconder for
that
thank you all in agreement
thank you very much so uh the report is
item nine on the agenda uh which is the
Malden Cemetery
yeah okay thank you Tara
that's all right
foreign